[Musique]
se découpant sur champ d'azur la ferme
tes faosses bien sûr et le Chae servant
de toi synthétique comme il se
doit au bout d'une allée de faux buit on
aperce fait un faux puit du fond duquel
la vérité n'avait jamais dû
[Musique]
remonter et la maîtresse de séant dans
un habit ma foi
sayant le fermière de comédie à ma
rencontre
descendit mon malheureux Bou est soudain
paru terne dans ce jardin prê des
massifs de fauses fleurs offrant les
plus vives
couleurs ayant foulé le faux gazon je la
suivi dans la maison
ou briller sans se consumer un genre de
feu sans
fumer face au faux buffet hen R 2 aligné
sur les rayons
de la bibliothèque en faux bois faux
bouquins achetés au
poid
faux auus son fausses armures faux
tableau de maîtres au
mur fausses perles et faux bijoux faux
grains de beauté sur les joues faux
ongles au bout des menotes piano jouant
des fausses notes avec des touches ne
devant pas le Riv voir aux
éléphants au lueur des fausses Chand
en levant ses fausses dentelles
elle a dit mais ce n'était pas sur tuer
mon premier
faux fausse vierge fausse pudeur fausse
fièvre
simulateur ces anges artificiels venus
d'un faux 7e
ciel la seule chose un peu sincère dans
cette histoire de faossè
et contre laquelle il ne faut peut-être
pas s'inscrire en faux c'est mon
penchant pour elle et mon gros point du
côté du poumon quand amoureuse elle
tombe d'un vrai marquis de
[Musique]
Carabas en l'occurrence Cupidon ce
conduisit en faux jeton en véritable
faux TM
et Vénus aussi
néanmoins ce serait sans doute mentir
par omission de ne pas dire que je leur
dois quand même une heure authentique de
vrai
[Musique]
bonheur